Avant des rapports de type sexuel, c'est un peu comme conduire un camion:
la première est un peu dure à passer, mais après ça roule tout seul.
Attendez, c'est nul comme comparaison ça.
Nan, avoir des rapports de type sexuel, c'est plutôt comme la raclette:
si on aime bien ça et que c'est bien préparé, c'est quand même vachement bon !
Oui mais attention. Oh oui, attention.
Parce que de la jouissance aux urgences, il n'y a parfois qu'un pas.
Alors laissez-moi vous mettre en garde avec ce top des accidents qui vous guettent si vous pratiquez le coït.
Premier drame de la population: la fracture de la verge.
La verge ou chibre, pénis, zizi, zigounette, teub... la verge donc, c'est pas un os, mais ça peut casser.
Ça arrive généralement pendant un rapport sexuel de type fougueux, voire un peu alcoolisé,
et particulièrement quand la personne qui possède le pénis n'a pas le contrôle du mouvement
c'est à dire quand il est en dessous dans la moitié des cas. Dans ce qu'on appelle un faux pas du coït,
le membre viril sort entièrement de l'orifice dans lequel il se trouvait et vient heurter une partie du corps plus dure.
S'ensuit un grand crac et l'albuginée se romps.
Alors l'albuginée c'est pas un légume,
c'est la capsule qui entoure le corps caverneux du pénis qui est gorgée de sang pendant l'érection.
Autant vous dire qu'en cas de fracture, l'érection elle disparaît instantanément et que le sang se répand partout sous la peau,
ce qui donne à l'organe une allure potagère !
...comme quoi le légyume on y vient finalement !
Bref dans ces cas là, il faut placer tout ça dans la glace, filer à l'hôpital se faire opérer, puis laisser le petit blessé tranquille pendant six semaines.
Six. Semaines.
Attention, ne pas confondre la fracture de la verge et la rupture du frein ! Vous savez, le petit bout de peau qui relie le gland au prépuce et qui peut lâcher aussi.
Ça saigne mais à l'extérieur cette fois, et il faut aussi souvent se faire opérer. C'est plus impressionnant, mais c'est moins grave.
Le pénis n'est pas le seul organe à se montrer facétieux, le vagin ne laisse pas sa part au chien en matière d'espièglerie !
Il peut par exemple se contracter violemment et emprisonner ce qui se trouve à l'intérieur, comme un sextoy, une langue pourquoi pas, ou le plus souvent, un pénis.
La mésaventure répond alors au nom de "Syndrome du pénis captif".
C'est sans danger mais c'est pas très confortable, surtout si on se rend à un rendez vous professionnel.
Pour mettre fin à la prise d'otages, il faut avoir quelques notions d'anatomie et savoir que les muscles en cause sont les releveurs de l'anus.
Ils se présentent sous la forme d'un double 8 dont les boucles entourent l'anus et le vagin, et ce qu'il faut surtout savoir c'est que les boucles ne peuvent pas se contracter en même temps.
L'astuce consiste donc à relâcher celle qui est autour du vagin en contractant celle de l'anus ,
et pour ça je vous fais pas de dessin, avec un doigt d'imagination vous devriez être capable de trouver tout seul.
La région anale, c'est l'ouzbékistan de la sexualité: c'est pas la zone la plus visitée, pourtant elle regorge de trésors et de surprises.
Les vrais savent ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
Mais ! On fait comme on aime.
Ce qu'on sait encore moins, c'est que la région débouche sur une zone qu'on appelle le rectum,
qui a la forme d'une ampoule et qui a la fâcheuse tendance à stocker tout ce qu'on lui confie.
Il n'est donc pas rare de voir arriver aux urgences une personne mal à l'aise, qui boîte un peu, et qui a toujours une explication
très crédible sur la façon dont sa bougie parfumée s'est trouvé coincée dans son ampoule rectale.
Alors je dis une bougie, mais ça peut être une réplique de statuettes des oscars ou une boule à neige hein.
Sur internet il y a une base de donnée très documentée sur la question,
vous irez voir si vous voulez, un vrai vide grenier !
Dans le jargon on appelle ça des corps étrangers du rectum.
Alors attention il n'y a pas de mal à se faire du bien, mais sachez quand même que si les médecins n'arrivent pas à retirer l'objet ou l'animal,
ça peut finir au bloc opératoire.
Douleur après le coït ? Rougeurs, oedèmes, démangeaisons? Et si ça n'était pas une infection, et si c'était...
UNE ALLERGIE AU SPERME ?!
Eh oui ça existe, et ça arrive à tout âge, et même après plusieurs années de relation avec le même partenaire !
Une allergologues m'a même raconté qu'une de ses patientes de 60 ans a fini en réanimation après un oedème généralisée et un choc allergique au sperme,
celui de son mari en l'occurrence.
Alors tout s'est bien terminé et la brave femme a même pu suivre un traitement de désensibilisation,
Vous savez, comme pour les allergiques aux pollen, quand on leur injecte un tout petit peu de pollen sous la peau pour que leur corps apprennent à se défendre.
Voilà bah pareil, sauf que là ce n'est pas du pollen qu'on injecte sous la peau.
Voilà ce top est terminé, surtout continuer à pratiquer la sexualité que vous aimez si vous aimez ça ,
la peur n'évite pas le danger et chaque problème a sa solution.
Et chacun voit midi à sa porte...à 14h.
...et...
...et abonnez-vous à DTC.
A la semaine prochaine !